we welcome to this video this is a 25-10
gameplay mode seco and this guy is
already right rating here in the 25
that's really high seeing the best list
yeah is the highest rated in that list
that's cool okay to 114 that's really
high so what about the other readings
hmm I only has plates standard I split
2510 like crazy ok so we going to go
forward Italian game here I also can't
play Knight f6 but this is a bit of a
tricky line with 95 wear black gives up
the pawn and I don't feel super
comfortable with that the Italian game
the pure Italian you with Bishop c5 is
really am a bit more bit more solid
let's aim very quick d3 yeah sometimes
my players go for a quick d3 here and
then like castles rookie one very
quickly okay he's not doing this but
very quickly putting pressure against
'if I've indirectly so that black has
problems in going d5 himself of course
what he's doing is it's entirely normal
it's taking taking its time there sorry
my voice is a bit under strain
so Bishop 187 that's a good little
improvement move going out of any
possible d 4 or before pushes okay
Bishop b3 yeah i think i'm going to
castle now I mean I don't want to take
only 3 and give him the open air file or
half open FL I usually let people take
on a seven and then just return with the
rook later if they do um okay that looks
a bit funny but well he he has played
like Bishop e3 and then takes on a 70
which is not really that brilliant in
terms of from Tempe so it's not not a
big problem that my Brooke is on a seven
and Scotty six I did not play age six
here he went Bishop e3 very early on so
I didn't really had to worry about a
possible Bishop g5 pin okay I wonder if
Bishop is six as a move here or not in
general I want to play but should be six
and go for that trait but maybe I can
prepare it with Queenie seven there
should be six sometimes those captures
our I quite tricky with D for coming
coming quickly and you don't know then
how to continue in the center with black
this is very this is a very simple way
to play here but I guess some quite okay
so interesting play with t4 here hmm I
didn't expect that
mmm if I take what I have to be aware of
is that that drew Khan is seven can
sometimes be attacked for example Bishop
c4 Nazi for ED for 94 94 Queen D for my
rookies attacked so those some details
can prove very complete to be very
important so maybe I should take on d
for him he takes CT eggs ok fortunately
I cannot go to five teams takes Bishop
c4 Nazi 494 and I don't believe it he's
got g5 and 24 m it's not not working at
all so yeah his he's threatening this um
this fork hmm i wonder if Bishop g4 is
in fact a move putting some pressure on
t form and yeah let's do that not
entirely sure what to do here Bishop
takes you for certain he was possible
but hard to say what's better ok it's a
simple way to play I wonder if I could
back if he just just goes for g4 maybe
he does but that is least turn leads to
some some imbalances some interesting
claim
before definitely would be an idea for
what if the center wasn't yeah wasn't
fluid like I'd say here there he always
has to consider something captures on d4
d5 and what if he goes d file a place in
six there's something going on in the
center if he would have the same
position with the porn on 23 then g-form
really looks a lot more attractive not
saying that he cannot play it he might
might be able to but okay he's closing
down the whole position interesting so
the question is do I want to take on f3
now or not yeah i think i will do that
now that the pressure on the center is
is gone after d5 my bishop is probably
not so useful anymore so going to take
it and I've got less space so trades are
ok and the bishops are not that great
anyway him the question is that night
where to go with it unite the eight does
have some point 98 98 g6 kind of the way
I play in my in my room but I'm not sure
about it I can also go nitey 890 bd7 g6
98 97 then f5 this kind of a DM white
Bishop on c4 or in general them a light
squared Bishop in this position is
always how to assess piece doesn't look
particularly great but quite often it
will still be effective in the long run
one idea for him is he a 5a 5b for move
the bishop back then maybe c 4 or a 5 b4
b5 directly man that gives me see if I
probably not yeah we'll see what he's
doing complicated position it's
something that you know he was going for
that it's a structure that somewhat
resembles randoms oh and bogo Indian
structures with the dark squared bishop
traded the only thing yeah that was to
be expected i'm going to go for for that
f5 IDM I wonder if night h5 is is
feasible is that yeah maybe this is a
little bit more no I have to go back
maybe night h5 is a little bit more
irritating in a way it has snide f form
in some cases
yeah that is making some sense preparing
c4 c5 it's not so easy to play if I go
night h5 here now I mean I will do that
anyway so no use in spending time here I
need to prepare a five at this position
mmm what I wonder is if I go F 5uf GF he
might be able to go F for as my queen is
unprotected no it's not doing that at
all interesting so is he going for some
nights five I know is not the fgf 94 is
an idea for sure so I night f4 is also
in
that 94 idea looks annoying so anyway to
prepare that somehow f-5e fgf 94 hmm
can't really move the Queen hear a funny
ideas crew d8 be a day 7 s as an old
Rubenstein idea he has played that in a
game I don't remember his opponent one
of Ruin Stein's are classics classic
maneuvers but I don't think it's an idea
here trading queens probably helps wide
with the c4 c5 ideas any possible
counter play that i have on the kingside
will always involve some kind of danger
for a white skin some and a bit
reluctant trade queens so f5 even native
form
I could try f6 Queen g7 and then f5 hmm
looks it looks very slow
yeah it's slow but it's not not
necessarily bad night f4 is of course
also in
but after night therefore I don't really
see what my what my next plan is
hmm it's probably going c4 c5 f 64
inches 75mm i move the Queen from e7 the
c5 move gets easier for him to play ok i
want to say another ideas f5 takes rook
shakes but that really doesn't doesn't
seem right until 90 form
hmm I'm not sure what to do c4 c5 is
also coming quickly i have absolutely no
options on the queenside absolutely no
hmm yeah maybe it's still f5 I mean the
night ugh comes to d4 but hmm I feel I
need some kind of counter play there on
the on the f file if I'm just sitting
there it looks it doesn't look good okay
f5 EF let's check once rook takes 94
Rugare 6 and then a possible 96 this
night to f8 and i can t and play 97 and
when that porn probably works them
probably okay let's do it not with a not
super happy with it but I'd have
completely overlooked that there's going
to be a fork em gee form I absolutely
didn't think Bochy for okay i can
sacrifice on f3 Queen takes rook f8
Queen moves snider for ad that wasn't
planned but it's actually quite a decent
decent compensation looks it looks looks
okay not sure if it is enough but it
seems like it seems playable I really
didn't think about what she for only
only late in this longer longer thing I
cannot go EF rook takes g4 who got three
Queen a three night afore immediately
because of Queen f
okay he takes f if i play GTX 94 I
wonder how bad that really is okay
anyway I'm going to go going to go for
that I think I really think that g4
cheeks look at eight should be enough
compensation the night on f4 is so
strong I mean maybe I'm maybe I'm a
computer will will like White's position
but it is definitely not easy at all to
play for a human player 95's mentioned I
go to gap 6 and 96 than 90 f 8 trying to
trade off the night maybe f4 is a move
then
and for a form maybe it's probably not
convincing we'll see I mean maybe he
goes 4g phones any 94 thoughts are
completely am yeah complete waste of
time
and so rook f6 I think f6 saw night is
69 f8 the move that irritates me is that
f4 at the end 90 x 90 x rook takes Queen
take so what about rook f 696 and I g70
vortex e7 that's clear let f move 90s
look at six 96 98 f for its really
really really annoying achieve on f4
okay I can take with the pawn can take
with the porn ok so I'm going back what
issue is that a lot in threatening to
take the night my queen is just wrong
Ollie 796 actually a possible move I
cannot probably can well maybe I can
take okay it's not going to happen Maxie
successor it's just probably silly
because I can move the Queen so night is
69 f eight if he M trades I think I'm I
can be reasonably happy if he lets me
take then I'm going to well take you six
d6 night to g7 then and try to pick up
that pawn
that should be ok I guess look a tune ok
so maybe night to g7 huh now then f4 is
going to be played I have night f5
actually night f5 Knight takes rook
chicks now that should be ok it should
be ok mm f4 @ on IG 7f 495 Queen nan
also ok let's do it and not prepare a
time loss in this 2510 game
I'm not going to f4 because I've thought
that and that it's mostly about 9 f 59 f
5m so night f5 if you move the Queen I
think I can take I mean I'm covering E 5
with my night so maybe it is it just
takes but can also just move move the
Queen I'm on d7 where I'm pressure I've
am covering and maybe it's got Bishop a
four at the end that could be a problem
actually some kind of Bishop a for
undermining my night and then it goes at
four but the f4 move is really only
possible because my queen isn't on the
e-file whenever I move Queen to them
young f7 or g7 and he actually has to
take only five but there might be some
issues but I still feel like I'm under
pressure here in this position Quincy
one could be interesting so 94c deform
just attack the c7 pawn now very much
hmm yep he went for that
this still is there still is some some
f4 in in some cases 94 cd4 I cannot
really move the night is too much
pressure on e5 if i move the queen is
going to play 96 mmm
okay so let's say 94 CD for Queen d8d
595 Claire for now it's not not good not
a good position John Knight a5 probably
wasn't good young due to Quincy one hmm
don't see a good movie
and I the five was wrong probably
remarkable
not seeing a good movie and not at all
and he's got f4 and now this is really
really really really bad plus 96 with 95
I have given up my protection all of the
six square any other way to play that
takes takes rook c8 so you can Bishop a
form
well think I'm completely outplayed it
looks bad really bad
I only see no move him maybe I'm
something like that I don't know it's
just a very bad position neither five
what was really wrong maybe I'm in big
trouble anyway but it's some Quincy one
was very strong yeah I actually called
the move the moment before he played it
so it's not like completely out of this
world to find it i also saw it just a
bit too late
and for is a very brutal move if he's
going for that
can I cannot completely believe it but
it might find still might still be his
choice yeah I'm not even sure what I
play on 96 if I go night f8 you will
have a forum maybe may I can somehow
what this but it doesn't look good
I really has played a ton of 25 10 games
though some very fresh accounts here
only he do just see a couple of standard
the one he lost one and there's all only
winds here only wins in 25 10 they have
many relatively low rated relatively low
rated players and lots of aborted it's a
bit strange okay bishop a phone yeah
that move was also of course in them in
the mix
can I debate is going F form at least
that's what I believe 94 c form
therefore is working they're always pins
working on the e-file
but take on d4 c4c 7 Hank sandy 5 hangs
indirectly yeah and again night fh this
F forum in a debate is not really great
great to begin with move the green to
finally attack the night Queen f7 maybe
this is a slight drawback of the bishop
move it is getting out of that be three
of seven diagonal yeah maybe maybe do
that I don't really as I mentioned a
couple of times I don't see anything
good anyway maybe this is playable
somehow night is 69 evade now it's very
strong plane
yeah maybe you can still go night e 6 11
of the probably not yeah one idea was
that f4 now can be answered by 94 cd4
look at four so I had some idea with
them with the Queen move so it's going
back that's actually good news he's
going back he still has nitin g5 v 6 up
is up his sleeve the queen is very
annoying on c1 star like age 6 he might
even have some g for business on a night
move then queen age 6 yeah I wonder if
he's threatening a 95 followed by
followed by a form that's really really
possible maybe just back to g7 en this
northern 9527 again f1 hmm
I really like to prevent 95 if possible
but I don't see how
ledge 795 27 f 4 ok can I get to the
night from d7 maybe to evade again he's
going 95 cringe 7 + f4 very probably
no g5 is not not very nice to face soon
let's say look G 895 again I'm always
how is need to go to to e7 which is
really not very desirable lady 795 and
that's always the e-file
yeah I wonder maybe 9 f8 is the the
relatively best option I have it looks
bad 95 97 f for it just just no good and
I also don't see how I can prevent
therefore I mean really absolutely I
don't see a way to prevent it
now you played that really well okay I'm
going here i don't i don't see a
playable move maybe queen age six is
even better but 95 is good night g5
Queenie 7 LF four looks looks bad
I was briefly thinking about something
like f for Luke a to f8 Bishop d7 rook
takes a form but he has some 96 probably
got very likely amongst other things but
f-for really is the moon from now if
he's not doing that I think I'm not in
not that bad shape
for maybe it's night h5 and move then
night h5 Bishop g7 loop check there for
wacky tactics double attacking night and
Bishop it's just a defense for a
four-night h5 Bishop e7 ruka 496 m 27
night a four-night f form ok if i get
that i probably have to be happy with it
not that it is great but probably
yeah I don't see anything else than f 44
m night age five mmm
yeah I have to have to do that if if he
goes at forum I don't see it don't see
some other option rucca wait maybe look
f8 Bishop d7 look F for that then other
that other way well night and Bishop are
hanging night is six Queen the sound and
i def a drop dead rock f1 also pretty
imagine exchange for not much
yeah I don't see em a drawback to f4
really don't looks very powerful
look f age yeah rook f8 Bishop d7 rook F
496 27 9 f 8 9 f8 rock everyone yeah
this is this is no compensation really
night after night h5 Bishop d7 rook a
form nighty 627 lighter for nada form at
least I have some powerful looking night
on a form looking it looks good but I
don't don't believe it's doing that much
yeah and the way you play that I mean he
played a very very very strong chest so
probably not going to let it slip no but
I didn't see anything I mean he is
threatening to take g75 and end of game
yeah so we'll graph 496 as I saw most of
his moves but I was really not able to
to find to find something good against
it or against them
it's a double attack so he probably has
to go 96 but it is also completely
completely as sufficient that maybe you
maybe in consign me I can somehow
somehow fight with this closed position
I don't have four it's not so bad but
I'm I believe that yeah i'm talking
about 96 queen d 7 94 94 and that this
night might still be expelled with the
jeep or move
then the FL will be dangerous nice very
diligent here serially out for anything
better than 96 maybe there is something
better I'm not ruling this out it's a
bit of a weird thing actually I mean
there really something else then 96 no
we had him some grabbing here maybe
takes long now to take on therefore no
it's not doing that g-form hmm okay that
is a strong
now very strong 93 night f4f rookie 7
hmm probably no move from sesam
something that I can try getting
somewhere against his King
yeah Night Moves lose and I really don't
see what I can do when IG 39 f 492
that's 92 or working nicely together and
93 look G 2 will probably win as well
hmm ok so i have two black resign resign
that yeah that was very well played
that's either very strong player or i
have to mention this possibility or an
engine and it looks like a very good
game by white so let's have a look there
see three it's all very normal now we
went Bishop e3 as I said I usually let
let people take so this is also
definitely not the mistake or anything
this is still all right d6 a form and
prepare this Bishop 6 move and I'll d4
are playing in the center and so Bishop
g4 h3 here now we went t5 ok I went with
this go into my actually Queen cheeks
why not night takes isn't that the more
natural muth anyway Queen takes I went
back in five is normal 97 be 4g 323 yeah
that looks normal okay 8
most Musa that very natural should be 39
h5 Knight f3 this is this is a strong
nice looking to prevent that f5 push and
ultimately that proved to be a problem
Knight f3 yeah and probably I cannot
play this so yeah stockfish is giving
g-form its let's by the way the first
move g4 is the first move that that
stock first suggests differently from
what he played the other moves were one
hundred percent correlation but it
doesn't really mean that he's cheating
i'm just saying i think i cold-called
most of the moose 93 however is very
yeah not sure if that move would occur
to me that idea with with operating with
94 against f5 him so yeah g-force what
the engine is giving here after which I
wanted to go for and computer actually
stop push wants to go here here here and
gives white one pawn yeah I mean this is
not at all easy the night is very strong
when f4 and the bishop is not not doing
that much it was a little bit born out
of necessity that that idea but I'm not
not sure that it is bad okay 94 I went
back look a two words so that's a cool
move
six already was interesting for sure
there's also g3 a couple of interesting
moves we went back plate there tnite f5
the sister seems to be it seems to be
wrong I mean wide of course is better
but not i'm not really sure how much
yeah I couldn't really find a move a
good move this was kind of I don't know
what to do but I couldn't really find a
move I was were you thinking he's
threatening F already the engine is
stopped which will just suggest this I
would have thought that a force
basically is good yeah queen it is good
now the evaluation is climbing and
climbing and I'm falling apart here in
the center yeah when I was going for
this I was seeing of course that I have
some square weaknesses but I thought I
can can cover them and maybe do
something on the FR but it never never
materialised should be three
yeah probably right i mean the bishop is
not doing that much yeah i know he went
he just went back i'm blocking their
file for the f porn but still i mean i'm
not i don't have a move this is not
helping but I didn't see move he's going
for 95 and F for the stock fish gives be
five I briefly thought about the move
but I thought that even the simple
captcha would be good and means looks
like rubbish maybe it's better than the
game yeah very likely it's better than
the game yeah this is probably then the
better defense relatively speaking a
line that are also mentioned 96 takes
9fe to f8 look everyone but why does
when white is winning here he's just too
active that night it's not doing
anything I think he can even go here and
take away those squares okay I tried
that and of course f1 after which I can
reside with the clear conscience that
was very a strong game by white
unfortunately am as we don't have any
information about him other than that he
yeah why white there were many board
games on the first move I don't know why
actually again
mmm will defend is always important
against cool defender maybe they're
friends or something it happens yeah
there's always the shadow of doubt on
those games if you play someone who's
untitled on the SSC and has a new
account but he played that very in very
strong waving in doubt I'm not sure
about the English expression there but
innocent until proven guilty or
something like that very strong game by
more mod seek oh ok well thanks for
watching